- It’s O’Neal and Bryant.
Their ability to work together is the
linchpin of any hopes the Lakers have.
- Shaq and the Lakers, they’re swept out of the playoffs.
- Kobe Bryant, Shaquille O’Neal.
- Are the Lakers running out of time?
- Shaq better get comfortable
because Kobe’s not gonna change.
- [Kobe Bryant:] All that stuff is old.
You know, people just wanna keep on talking about it
and dragging him in the mud.
- [Shaquille O’Neal:] Really don’t have to be buddy-buddy.
- [Phil Jackson:] At some level, somebody’s will has to give.
- [Bryant:] We have to win. There’s no other option.
- [O’Neal:] We were up 3-1. We got cute a lotta times.
We let our guards down.
- That aura of invincibility has been pierced big-time.
- This sets up an unbelievable Game 7.
- [O’Neal:] They were the toughest team, and
they were the only team that wasn’t scared of us.
So, for me, I was kinda nervous,
but I knew that I had to come out and play well,
which didn’t happen.
I didn’t have one of those Shaq-like games at all.
- Still no Shaquille O’Neal for the Lakers.
- This is a 15-point game.
- This crowd is stunned.
- [O’Neal:] Now, for us, in our head, we got tired of failing.
And if we don’t get this one, just be another,
“Oh, they had a good year, but, you know, they failed.”
I know I definitely would have been the scapegoat
if we didn’t win that game, and I probably would have
been gone right away.
I was scared, scared of that
if we didn’t get it done, it’ll be over.
Kobe vs. Shaq feud thing gonna come up.
I just let everybody down.
Then in the fourth quarter, I got rollin’ a little bit.
I hit one off the glass.
- They get it deep to Shaq, and he connects off the glass.
- [O’Neal:] But I kept telling Kob,
“Hey, I’m wide open at the rim.”
And he said, “I gotcha. I gotcha.”
The last play, I wasn’t even lookin’ for the ball cuz I was
like, “OK, Kobe gonna shoot in the fourth quarter.
Get it to Kobe and just get out the way.”
So he got it, and he crossed Scottie Pippen up.
And [Brian] Grant left me, and I just threw my hand up.
I almost didn’t jump
cuz I didn’t think he was gonna throw it.
But when he threw it up, I said,
“Oh, shit, this is not a shot.”
So I had to get up, and he actually threw it up too high.
If I’d have jumped a second later or jumped too early,
I’d have missed it.
And I didn’t wanna take a chance bein’ cute.
- To Shaq!
- [O’Neal:] I just threw it through real quick.
That was the defining moment
of our, of our dominant run.
But that was, you know, the beginning of the,
of the great Laker three-peat.
And that solidified us being the most enigmatic,
most controversial, most dominant
one-two punch ever created.
People always ask about our relationship.
You got two strong-minded people
that are gonna get it done their way.
The respect will never be lost.
But when it comes to be inside the lines and win,
that’s what me and him, that’s what we did.